[Music]
and she needs you Game of Thrones fans
still reeling from that hookup at the
end of season seven buddy real-life kid
Harrington aka John snow is gearing up
to say I do to his former co-star Rose
Leslie this weekend
the tents are already up at Rose's
family home
Wardell castle in scotland yep the
actress grew up in a castle the historic
estate has been in her family for 900
years the couple have invited many of
their co-stars there's Peter Dinklage
and Emilia Clarke arriving at the
airport today we've watched the couple's
fairytale romance unfold off and on
screen what's your name hey grace
we met on this show it's such a special
thing I'm so so privileged there couple
fell in love while shooting scenes in
Iceland their chemistry was immediately
noticed by fans the way that kids nice
or it was that mean they were very much
in love with one another rose was on
Thrones for three seasons before dying
in her lover's arms but with kids still
on the show and shooting in remote
locations and Rose joining a new show
the good fight the couple had to make it
work long distance that means spending
most of your free time on FaceTime then
there you go
the king of the north has come a long
way since season 1 and even though he
met his bride to be on the show the 31
year old is ready to leave Jon Snow
behind and plans to chop off his
signature locks when filming wraps
come on tell me shoot him good kids on
screen sister sophie turner just arrived
in Scotland for the wedding she's
planning her own I Do's with Joe Jonas
Sophie was just 13 when she landed her
first ever acting gig as Sansa Stark
dyeing her natural blonde hair red for
the role pretty low so now 22 year old
credits the show with helping her grow
up it was definitely an education in all
things it was an education in sex for
sure so far Thrones has earned 110 Emmy
nods and 38 wins that's the most ever
for a Drama Series productions still
underway for the eighth and final season
the final six episodes will air in 2019
but the Millia Clarke is already
starting to say her goodbyes this week
she posted a tribute on Instagram
telling you - she can't help but cry
when she reads her scripts I find it
rich and uni it's really tricky talking
about its it life makes me sad
I am absolutely heartbroken to be safe
[Music]